انزلي نسكي مخاطبا شعبه وعلينا والصمود
هذا الشتاء للبقاء يحيى
الحلقه الصحيه لاسطوره كره القدم قرار من
الفيفا يسعد الجماهير المغربيه قبل مباراه
اسبانيا هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقلها لكم من
قناه العربيه اهلا بكم
مع اقتراب فصل الشتاء يبدو
سيكون هناك برد قارس جدا في اوكرانيا
كلمه لشعبه طلبه فيها بالصمود والمثابره
في وجه القوات الروسيه قال في كلمته
اليوميه عبر الفيديو ان العدو يعمل بشده
في استخدام الشتاء ضدنا لجعله بردا ومشاقه
وجزء من الارهابه مضيفا ان اتحمل هذا
الشتاء هو الدفاع عن كل شيء على حده فيما
تشير تقارير الى ان ملايين الاوكرانيين
يواجهون السقيعه والبرد وسط انقطاع
الكهرباء والمياه احيانا نتيجه قذف البنا
التحتيه الطاقه
نزل اسطوره كره القدم البرازيلي فيليه
تصدر حديثه وسائل الاعلام والسوشيال ميديا
بعد انباء عن تدهور حلته الصحيه والجديد
هذه المره هو اعلان اثنتان من بناته بان
وضعه الصحي لا يمثل اي خطر النت ليه كلي
ناس منذ قالت في مقابله مع محطه برازيليه
ان والدها موجود حاليا في المستشفى بسبب
التهاب في الرئه وعندما يتحسن سيعود الى
المنزل فيما قالت شقيقتها فلافيا انبيليه
ليس في وحده العنايه المركزه انه في غرفه
عاديه مشيره الى انه ليس في خطر ويخضع
للعلاج
في خبر اسعد مشجعي المنتخب المغربي استجاب
الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم فيفا لمناشطه
الجماهير المغربيه الموجوده في قطر بعد
نفاذ التذاكر مواجهه اسود الاطلس امام
اسبانيا صفحه منتخب المغرب على موقع تويتر
اعلنت ان الفيفا خصص 5000 تذكره اضافيه
للمباراه التي ستجمع بين اسود الاطلس
واسبانيا في اطار دوري الثمن النهائي من
المونديال مشيره الى وضعها في موقع
الاتحاد الرسميه ببيع التذاكر وسط امال
كبيره دلاله الجماهير في تاهل المغرب
للدور ثمن النهائي
[موسيقى]
من جديد عادت قضيه الثنائي الامريكي جوني
ديب وتلقته للواجهه
وتعادت لتتصدر التراند في مواقع التواصل
بعدما طالبت الاخيره بمحاكمه جديده تقارير
افادت بان الممثله الشقراء تقدمت باستئناف
الى محاكم فرجينيا مطالبه بالغاء قرار
المحكمه الذي جاء لمصلحه ذاب او بمحاكمه
جديده في قضيه التشهير التي رفعها ضدها
زوجها السابق فيما اعتبر محامها ان
استبعاده ملاحظات العلاج الخاصه به ورد
والتي ابلغت فيها عن الاساءه التي تعرضت
لها من جاني ادت الى نتائج غير عادي في
المحاكمه على حديقه لهم
هو في خبرنا الاخير الذي سيكون عنوانه
الفرحه فرحتينا اذا انجبت امراه امريكيه
من ولايه نورت كارولينا طفله وفازت في
اليانصيب في اليوم الذاتيه لتنهل عليها
التبريكات من الملايين على السوشيال ميديا
شبكات سي ان ان الامريكيه اوضحت ان السيده
ربحت مئه الف دولار في نصيب باور بول بعد
ساعه قليله فقط على ولادتها قائله اشعر
وكان طفلتي قد جلبت لي الحظ انا ممتنا
للغايه فيما اشارت الى انها استخدمت اعياد
ميلاد ابنائها لاختيار ارقام التذكره
الرابحه